en este vídeo vamos a conectar el
interruptor de corriente y los cables de
energía a nuestro controlador de 298
aquí tenemos los cables de corriente que
colocamos en un vídeo anterior y pueden
ver que tenemos un cable corto y un
cable largo vamos a juntar y torcer los
cables positivos de las baterías ya que
vamos a cablear nuestras baterías en
paralelo porque queremos mantener
siempre igual
nuestro voltaje y así poder aumentar el
tiempo de funcionamiento de nuestro
robot ahora vamos a unir torciendo ambos
cables con el cable corto de nuestro
interruptor los torcemos todos juntos y
ya que están bien unidos tomaremos
nuestro cautín que ya está caliente y
pondremos un poco de soldadura para
asegurarnos de que se mantengan unidas
después quitamos el exceso de cable y
ahora vamos a usar plástico envolvente
quizá ustedes no tengan este tipo de
tubo plástico envolvente pero no se
preocupen pueden usar cinta aislante
eléctrica para envolver todo el metal el
tubo de plástico envolvente mantiene las
cosas mejor sujetadas pero necesitan
tener esta pistola especial para
calentar este tubo si no la tienen
siempre pueden usar la cinta aislante
negra para envolver todos los cables de
metal calentamos este tubo para que se
encoja y aísle mejor los cables y evitar
que estos toquen cualquier otra cosa y
causar posibles problemas así que
queremos asegurarnos de que todos los
cables están cubiertos o aislados ahora
tomamos nuestro interruptor y ponemos
silicón caliente encima de todos los
contactos del interruptor y hacemos esto
porque normalmente este circuito se
encuentra en la parte de abajo de la
lámpara ya que no queremos que nada
toque estos contactos eléctricos pero
ahora este interruptor no va a estar en
la parte de abajo de la lámpara y podría
tocar algún elemento de metal
ocasionando un cortocircuito o haciendo
que la electricidad se vaya por algún
lugar del circuito que no queremos lo
que podría ocasionar los problemas ahora
que ya ha secado el silicon y esta parte
del circuito está protegida podemos
tomar el cable largo del interruptor y
conectarlo en nuestro bloque de
terminales de nuestro controlador del
motor que está para nuestra terminal
positiva así que vamos a tomar nuestro
cable largo y lo vamos a colocar en la
terminal que está más a la izquierda y
es importante que lo coloquemos justo
aquí nuestro cable quedó un poco largo
así que vamos a cortarlo y apelar un
poco el extremo recuerden que es
importante que no quede cable expuesto
sin aislar ya que no queremos que pueda
tocar otra pieza de metal recordamos que
el cable largo debe estar colocado en la
terminal que está en la extrema
izquierda es ahí donde deben llegar los
9 volts de la batería
ahora vamos a tomar un par de cables uno
va a ser de dos y media pulgadas o seis
centímetros o incluso podría ser de tres
pulgadas o 7.5 centímetros el otro cable
va a medir cinco pulgadas o 12.5
centímetros pelamos los extremos de los
cables recuerden que estamos con los
cables de las baterías y los estamos
dejando listos para conectar estos son
los cables negativos o de tierra de la
batería vamos a pelar los lo que a veces
es difícil pues estas pinzas peladoras
sirven muy bien para cables de núcleo
sólido pero estos son de núcleo de red
lo que a veces hace que se corten los
cables así que hay que tener cuidado
vamos a exponer un poco más de cable en
los extremos casi unos 8 milímetros o 3
octavos de pulgada torcemos juntos estos
cables los dos cables negros que son los
negativos y ahora torcer hemos estos con
los dos cables negros de nuestras
baterías de manera que nos quede una
conexión sólida de la misma forma que lo
hicimos con los cables del interruptor
ya que tenemos una conexión sólida vamos
a soldar la para evitar que se separen
y ya que nuestra soldadura ha cubierto
todos los cables que unimos
vamos a cortar el cable que sobresale
ahora tomamos nuestras pinzas y
apretamos la soldadura para darle forma
y que quede suave y pareja y podamos
colocarla en la terminal central de
nuestro controlador el que está en medio
de estas tres terminales lo colocamos
aquí y usamos nuestro destornillador
para cerrar el tornillo y que no se
mueva ahora vamos a tomar nuestro cable
negro largo y lo doblamos hacia atrás y
al pequeño vamos a pelar su extremo unos
5 milímetros y lo mantenemos al frente y
ahora tomamos otro cable de 3 pulgadas
de longitud o 7.5 centímetros es un
cable rojo que vamos a pelar en los
extremos unos 5 milímetros y lo vamos a
conectar en la terminal que está a la
extrema derecha de los tres bloques
terminales lo que nos dará un potencial
eléctrico de 5 volts para nuestro
arduino el cual vamos a conectar en un
momento
vamos a conectar nuestros cables de
acoplamiento de pines tenemos cuatro
cables de acoplamiento tenemos cuatro
cables de acoplamiento hembra a hembra y
los vamos a conectar a los pines de
nuestro controlador vamos a poner
nuestros cuatro cables acopladores en
cada pin no importa en qué orden los
coloquemos y ya que los tenemos todos
conectados pues estaremos listos para
conectar nuestro arduino